Hey guys, it's Jan here. If you've watched
my review and my 25 fun facts video, you'll
know I really enjoyed Disney's latest animated
movie, Zootropolis.
So, I wanted to look back over the five funniest
moments from the movie.
Obviously, spoilers ahead if you haven't seen
the film already!
And I've got a great giveaway to win this
beautiful Art of Zootropolis hardback book.
It'll be on my Zootropolis easter egg video,
so make sure you're subscribed and I'll add
a link here to the video as well when it's
ready.
Kicking off at number 5 is Nick and Judy's
encounter with Yax the hippie yak and his
au naturel furry friends at the Mystic Spring
Oasis.
I like the fact that although Yax seems to
be a bit out of it, he's actually the one
who remembers every detail of Mr Otterton's
last visit while Nangi, the yoga-practising
elephant, has no recollection whatsoever of
the missing otter.
All of which, of course, turns on its head
the saying that 'elephants never forget.'
And what about that brilliant scene at the
DMV, aka the Department of Mammal Vehicles,
which is staffed solely by sloths?!
Nick's friend Flash takes literally all day
to look up a licence plate to help Judy.
I love the pacing of this scene, the pauses
Flash takes between words, his absolute insistence
on finishing each and every sentence even
when the conversation's already moved on,
and the way he reacts to Nick's joke, a smile
spreading super-slowly across his face and
his eyes until he's actually laughing.
Oh, and of course, it's funny to watch the
change in Judy's reactions as she goes from
positively perky at the start to full-on frustrated
by the end, and I just love the way Nick sort
of glances at her from the side, a half-smirk
on his face, because he knows exactly how
this is going to go down.
I absolutely adore the whole elephant ice
cream parlour scam that Nick pulls.
It's just such a beautifully thought-out and
animated sequence of events, with loads of
great jokes throughout.
You've got Nick and his supposed elephant-loving
son who pull a fast one on an unwitting Judy,
getting her to pay for their jumbo popsicle.
Then they melt that Jumbo pop on a rooftop,
and pour the liquid into tracks left by Finnick's
paws in Tundratown's snow which creates 'Pawsicles'
which they sell to a bunch of suit-wearing
banker Lemmings, who then throw the sticks
into a recycling bin, where Finnick collects
them only for Nick to sell the sticks as red
wood to a bunch of tiny rodents!
It's such a genius way to introduce the character
of scam artist fox Nick and have him cross
paths with hard-working cop Judy.
At number 2 is the chase scene through Little
Rodentia.
This bit of the film is full of wonderful
sight gags and cleverly draws on a mix of
monster movies like Godzilla and sci-fi flicks
like Attack Of The 50-Foot Woman as we see
Judy pursuing the thief Duke Weaselton through
this tiny part of town.
It's so funny when Weaselton has a tiny rodent
car on each foot and uses them to skate away
from Judy, and when he has to force himself
into all sorts of crazy shapes as he tries
to make his getaway on top of a speeding train.
And what about when all the little rodents
are running screaming from Judy and she politely
apologises to them as she runs by.
And wasn't it cool when she saves Mr Big's
daughter from death by giant donut?!
And speaking of Mr Big, at number one is the
genius scene where Judy and Nick meet the
teeny tiny mob boss.
I just love that scene in all its Godfather-inspired
glory, from the moment his polar bear bodyguard
opens his hands to reveal that Mr Big is actually
a tuxedo-wearing arctic shrew with the voice
of Marlon Brando, to the movie's literal interpretation
of icing, Michael Giacchino's brilliant Godfather-style
music, and the whole chat about how Nick sold
Mr Big an expensive rug made of the fur of
a skunk's butt which Mr Big then used to bury
his grandmama!
And I can't forget the wedding scene with
all the shrews dancing, and the way the camera
pulls back to reveal they're actually all
on top of a little table with the polar bears
guarding it.
I could watch this particular bit of the movie
over and over again and still find it funny.
Ok, what are your favourite moments from Zootropolis?
And which bits made you really laugh out loud
the most?
I can't wait to find out in the comments below!
I've got a video on the way with all the Disney
and other movie easter eggs and references
I spotted in the film, and I'll update the
link here once it's live!
If you enjoyed this video, thanks so much
for hitting the thumbs-up and sharing, and
don't forget to subscribe for more videos
on Disney, Pixar, comic book movies, and more!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!